a lot on the minds of many of those
people in our audience who have
subscribed to our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash reddit I
was on there this morning Pat you're on
there as well right you'll you'll
sometimes pop up in the car oh yeah
every every few days Oh make my
appearance yeah don't go crazy don't no
don't start showing up there every day
Pat okay so let's look at some of the
popular and interesting discussions at
david pakman.com slash read it I hope
you will join us there first and
foremost the root of all evil in the US
a very interesting post from one of our
viewers listeners about the root of all
evil in the United States I encourage
you to check it out and join that
discussion also on reddit a post called
in regards to conservative trump's
russia leak story in other words the
story of eric erickson talking about the
Trump Russia leak an interesting
hypothesis and commentary and people
increasingly engaged in that discussion
very respectful discussion among people
who don't always necessarily agree also
from our reddit discussion forum a post
called springtime for Putin and Russia
is Trump guilty of illegal activity or
just part of a ruse that went too far
and I I really I don't know if you
looked at this one pad it's generating a
lot of discussion and it's the idea that
it's not so much that Trump was
complicit in in some kind of scandal or
plot but that this all started as a sort
of ruse it went too far an incompetent
sort of saw Trump wrapped up in it which
I don't know if that's giving Trump
credit or treating him like the sort of
clueless buffoon that we've learned
learned that he is it's but it's an
interesting hypothesis I think it's hard
to believe that he wasn't involved in
any way or at least his top campaign
advisors weren't involved fair enough
also from our reddit discussion forum my
thoughts about Donald Trump's mental
health this is in response to the
increasingly viral story from a couple
months ago which now is approaching
700,000 views on YouTube and about a
million views on Facebook about Donald
Trump possibly showing early signs of
dementia or Alzheimer's interesting
discussion you can participate in and
lastly if he goes there will be trouble
if he
there if he stays it will be double
making an argument that I actually think
is a pretty good argument pat which is
Donald Trump's impeachment and
successful removal from office would
bring with it a whole new series of
problems that could end up being worse
than just having a sort of scandalized
Trump in there for four years and we'll
touch on that next Monday but I think
there's a good case to be made for that
especially if he is impeached then is
Mike Pence really better than Donald
Trump I mean I don't think he is that is
one of the many relevant questions that
that are coming up so david pakman.com
slash read it please join our reddit
discussion forum a lot of good stuff
going on there and the moderators are
keeping the trolling down to to a dull
roar so I think you'll be pleased with
that